we were never
young so begins mikhail jole's memoir
we were born in a cult we were put in an
orphanage we escaped the cult
there was a lot of violence a lot of
fear in the notorious
california-based cult synonym kids were
separated from their parents
to be raised as children of the universe
as jolie writes in hollywood park our
parents were like ghosts in synanon
haunting us then disappearing again
leaving us to wonder what their
connection to us was supposed to mean
what is a mom and what is a dad and what
is a family
and if it's so special then why'd you
leave me how long can you live with
ghosts before deciding to become one
but i was lonely too the hardest part
wasn't that i was in the cult the
hardest part was i was lonely
synonym had started as a therapeutic
community
for alcoholics and drug addicts before
gaining popularity with others
like jolee's mother trying to create a
new way
to live but in recent months it has
sought to silence critics by lawsuits
and intimidation
by 1978 the organization was forcing
members
to shave their heads and swap spouses
synon has armed itself and taken a
defiant stance against its critics
and founder chuck diederich had
organized his own
military nobody is going to mess with us
nobody we were never young jolene was
just
five just too afraid of ourselves
when he says he watched a former member
brutally
beaten i remember them hitting him and i
remember um
our eyes locking he was beaten
unconscious
from the way you write about it it
stayed with you for quite a while
oh absolutely absolutely it followed me
around i mean i had nightmares about it
mikhail and his older brother fled with
their mom
to salem oregon
[Music]
after she became fearful of the group
somewhat far away but he says she would
frequently sink
into depression or what his
five-year-old mind
heard as the deep russian my mother
she tried to outrun her demons and i
really believed that
that she tried uh it just didn't work
at 11 he moved to los angeles to be with
his dad
an ex-con former synonym member and
recovering heroin addict
who would change his life
they loved going to the racetrack
together hollywood park
my dad and i had some really important
moments there kind of looked out over
the dirt oval and he said you know
you don't have to be like me you know
you're a smart kid go do something
better with your life
what did hearing your father say that
mean to you
oh god it meant everything to me when he
said that it was you know
he was telling me to go be my own person
he had seen
the alternative i watched my brother
start dealing with addiction
by the time he was 13 and i think it
scared me you know i think a lot of it
was i just decided to invent this person
who was the person you invented i was
the honors club president
you know track and field athlete ap
straight a student
my high school yearbook was like
everything says like remember me when
you're president
jolie would graduate from stanford and
distance himself from his mother
with whom he has not spoken in years
how do you feel about what you went
through with your mom now
it's really hard to hate someone who's
pain you know so well
and there's this part of me that's you
know i'm conflicted because on the one
hand there's a lot of anger
like i didn't have a childhood that's a
tough one
what do you do with that anger you know
you write books
he writes songs
[Music]
he wrote his new music
[Music]
and his memoir in his basement study
filled with inspirational sayings this
one's good you don't need confidence
just write
jolie saw his book as an artifact a
place to find his late father
and other relatives because you
understand so much my life was spent
looking for a family
and so i could create this artifact
where they're all there and how does
that feel
it feels good it feels mystical that's
probably the thing i'm most proud of
is to have honored them in that way
that it meant so much to me that i spent
three years locked in a room
uh trying to create a world where i
could do that
mikhail jolet is now married with two
young children
he said becoming a father and seeing his
son at six months
the age when many synonym kids were
separated from their parents
really put into sharp focus the impact
that has on children and that it had on
him
and he's now making sure to pick up and
hug his kids as much as possible
jolene's memoir hollywood park is on
sale now
wherever you buy your book scale
well i tell you anthony that was a great
tease i really want to read that i
remember
synonym unfortunately i'd never heard of
mikhail jolie until this very moment but
what a story he has my heart just opens
to him and it's good to see that he
seems to
have come out on the other side and is
okay wow
yeah he's thrived in many ways and it's
a beautifully written memoir he's a
wonderful writer too